i am so glad to have the opportunity
today
to uh
i guess bring you more evidence that my
instinct yesterday when we looked at
clips of donald trump's former attorney
general william barr saying trump's
election lies were bs and whatever it
doesn't make barr a good guy it doesn't
even make him a sensible guy
and the day after
these clips went viral of william barr
saying trump brought in a clown show of
lawyers after the election all of this
stuff
when pressed william barr still says
i'd vote for trump over a democrat if he
ran in 2024. this is exactly what i was
talking about yesterday bill barr after
saying trump lied about the election
he
uh incited the attack on january 6th etc
etc
he told savannah guthrie yesterday well
if it's trump versus a democrat of
course i'm going to vote for trump
because democrats are really really bad
this is why i say
these are not good people these people
are not our friends or any of it billbar
wants to sell books that's all that's
going on take a listen
you say in your book it's time for the
party to move on from trump liz cheney
has said he is not fit to serve and
should not be ever near the oval office
again do you agree with that
well i certainly
have made it clear i don't think he
should be our nominee and i'm going to
you know support somebody else for the
nomination but if he is the nominee and
you have your choices
donald trump or whoever's running on the
democratic side would you vote for him
uh
because i believe that the the greatest
threat to the country is the progressive
agenda being pushed by the democratic
party it's inconceivable to me that i
wouldn't vote for the republican nominee
so
even if he lied about the election and
threatened democracy as you write in
your book
well it's better than a democrat it's
hard to project what the facts are going
to turn out to be three years hence but
as of now it's hard for me to conceive
that i wouldn't vote for the record
even though he's a threat to democracy
a threat to our country
incited a riot
lied about who won the election
brought out a clown show of lawyers
i mean listen progressives are really
the threat
this is why these people are so
dangerous guys and this is why i told
you he stumbled across some small
factoid some small element of truth
but this is not a this is not a good guy
and it's the same thing with liz cheney
at the end of the day liz cheney maybe
wouldn't vote for trump against a
democratic nominee
but she still did vote with trump
something like 88 percent of the time
when trump was president just as a
reminder here's what william barr said
about trump yesterday but remember
he he'd still vote for trump over a
democrat and i told him that all this
stuff was
and
about election fraud
and uh
you know it was wrong to be shoveling it
out the way his team was
and he started asking me about different
theories and i had the answers i was
able to tell him this is wrong because
of this you're trying to set him
straight yes
and and and you know he listened
he he he was obviously getting very
angry about this i said okay well look i
understand you're upset with me
and i'm perfectly happy to
tender my resignation and then boom he
slaps the desk he slapped the desk and
he said accepted
accept it
and then boom he slapped it again accept
it
go home don't go back to your office
go home
so uh william barr saying that william
barr also referring to all those wacky
lawyers that trump hired to try to flip
the election as a clown show
and
about election fraud
and
it was wrong to be shoveling it out the
way his team was
and then he also told trump what he
thought of his legal team
not a lot
i said the reason you are where you are
is because you wheeled out a clown show
of lawyers
a clown show yeah clown car or something
like that i said yeah so uh anyway he'd
still vote for trump if there's a
democrat
i mean he says this guy's not fit to
serve he's a threat to the country
terrible for democracy all this stuff
well but no i mean listen i'm not going
to vote for joe biden completely you
know innocuous milktoast democrat who
you know will be lucky to have major
accomplishments that that change
american society or the economy in any
serious way it's actually almost worse
that you know there's the people who
think trump's great
it's like okay well i disagree with you
uh and i i would i would have that
argument with you but these people
realize trump is nuts a threat to
democracy unfit to serve and they still
say well if it's joe biden or connell i
mean i just can't imagine i would ever
vote for a democrat it's completely and
totally bonkers and this is exactly what
i was talking about when i was saying
this guy wants to sell a book that's all
he wants to do send me your thoughts you
can find me on twitter at dpakman
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions to
sleep better their flagship products are
the uhler sleep system and the cube
sleep system which is what i have both
are hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too and for a limited time
chili sleep has a special offer just for
my audience go to chilisleep.com
pacman to learn about the exclusive
discount the link is down below